the government never lets a crisis go to
waste so we have this horrific again un
it's it's an indescribably horrific
event that happened that transcends
politics uh that happened in new valley
last week okay
but everyone has made it about politics
and what is everything about right now
it's about taking away the guns we have
to make sure more people can't get guns
we have to take away guns from certain
people etc etc uh here's joe biden very
confused on uh high caliber weapons low
caliber weapons nine millimeters
etcetera etcetera and they showed me uh
uh x-rays
he said a 22-caliber bullet
will lodge in a lung
a nine millimeter bullet blows the lung
out of the body
so the idea of these
high caliber
weapons
is
[Music]
the constitution the second amendment
was never
okay first off let's do the last line
there i addressed it on friday that is
absolutely a lie the second amendment is
absolute and yes when the second
amendment was codified in the bill of
rights the average person was allowed to
have a cannon there was nothing that
said that they couldn't okay uh the idea
was that you could have a well-formed
militia that could stop government
tyranny stop government overreach okay
that's just so that's just a lie and he
just keeps saying it and nobody stops
him in the media okay the media is not
too good either i know you all get that
the other part of what he said in a very
mangled confused sort of way there was a
real escalation in terms of what the
democrats are doing on guns because in
essence he's supporting a ban on nine
millimeter handguns first off these are
low caliber weapons this is not a high
capacity weapon these are handguns uh
now it's interesting because justin
trudeau in the clip we just showed you
earlier was talking about banning
handguns and now you here have joe biden
in essence saying the same thing now he
may be confused i suppose every time he
says something you don't know if he
means it or they wrote it or he's just
going off the cuff or if he literally
has no idea what he's saying but he is
suggesting a ban on nine millimeter
handguns these are not ar-15s etcetera
etcetera so that's where joe biden is at
with this whole thing uh here's press
secretary jean pierre
talking about the age limit related to
buying assault weapons the average age
of suspects at school mass shootings is
18.
would the president support raising
the age at which someone can buy a gun
to 21. so the president was very clear
about this just recently when he said
that uh
that uh in his remarks just on tuesday
that it doesn't make sense for an 18
year old
uh to legally buy an assault weapon and
so he made very clear on tuesday when
after he landed from asia and had to
deal with such a devastating uh news
that happened in texas okay so first off
as i just noted to my guys as we were
playing the clip it's just so obvious
that all of the people basically except
for peter ducey at fox that are sitting
in the white house press conferences
they're just plants they're government
plants who ask the exact questions that
they want that the administration wants
them to ask now as far as this 18 to 21
issue and the age of the people who are
mass shooters because we obviously have
a mass mental health problem in this
country and we also have an issue with
young men in a society that wants to
throw these people away especially if
they're young straight white men is
there some discussion to have related to
the age limit when buying a gun there
probably is there probably is does it
make sense that you can't drink at 18
but you can go to war right
the voting age all of these
inconsistencies related to all of these
things so is there some discussion
perhaps that 18
related to your full uh you know your
brain health and all of these things
your brain maturity
is there some discussion to have about
that of course there is now the problem
is that because the left never stops
you can see them making the move right
now now we're going to stop certain set
of people from getting getting guns and
we're going to start talking about that
handguns will be moved and we're going
to ban all assault weapons even though
we're not exactly sure what those are
all of these things this is where i am
so sympathetic
to people on the right
who years ago maybe i thought were more
extreme in a certain degree that if you
give the left an inch on anything if a
crisis happens and then you negotiate in
the midst of that crisis they will just
keep coming and coming and coming show
me one instance where these people ever
stop
foreign